[Music]
thank you very much for joining us we
begin with breaking news the main Bridge
linking Crimea with Mainland Russia has
been damaged after an explosion security
camera footage appears to show a huge
blast at the Kirch straight Bridge
earlier Saturday morning Russia's
National anti-terrorism Committee says
it was caused by a truck bomb part of
the road section of the Kirch Street
crossing has now collapsed and a fuel
tanker train on the rail overpass caught
fire the bridge is a vital Supply route
for Russia's forces in southern Ukraine
present Vladimir Putin drove a truck
across the bridge to inaugurate it in
2018 at the time it was the only land
Corridor between Crimea and the Russian
mainland
well we have two correspondents standing
by for us on the story where he
challenges in Kiev we'll be speaking to
him in just a moment but first Muhammad
Val who's in Moscow
Muhammad this is a critical link for
Moscow what is the reaction from the
Kremlin
the reaction we have now is from uh
former president Dimitri Medvedev who is
now the deputy chairman of the National
Security Council he basically said that
a little while ago or days ago one of
the Ukrainian officials spoke of the
need to strike at that particular bridge
I hope he said I hope he understands
what the retaliatory goals will be he
also said in July in July he said if
they hit Crimea Judgment Day Will Come
for them so I mean this is a very strong
reaction from Medvedev and also the
speaker of the state Duma he described
what happened as an act of War on Russia
so very obviously Russian leadership
very angry with what happened they
consider it a a terrorist act and Russia
has promised or vowed to react to any
type to this particular type of of
attack on its uh what it considers its
territory and its interests thank you
for that Muhammad Val live there in
Moscow let's get the reaction now from
Kiev Rory challenges in the Ukrainian
Capital Forest Rory what are the
ukrainians saying about this
well there's a lot of insinuation uh but
no explicit confirmation that this was
the behavior the results the actions of
Ukraine's military the most austere tone
I think was taken by mikhailo pedoliak
who's an advisor to the president
zelensky alongside a picture of the
Burning Bridge he wrote on Twitter
Crimea the bridge the beginning
everything illegal must be destroyed
everything's stolen must be returned to
Ukraine everything occupied by Russia
must be expelled other official Twitter
accounts had a bit more fun uh with this
the secretary of the National Security
and defense Council of Ukraine had a
picture of the Burning Bridge alongside
Marilyn Monroe singing Happy Birthday Mr
presidents well of course yesterday
Friday was Vladimir Putin the president
of Russia's 70th birthday uh sick burn
was the simple comment from another
official Ukrainian account but I suspect
that behind this bravado there is a bit
of nervousness in in Ukraine about
what's the response from Russia might be
this is a huge blow to them both
logistically and in terms of psychology
as well logistically it makes it very
very difficult for the Russians to
supply their troops in the south of
Ukraine fighting against Ukrainian
forces there the use of rail networks is
absolutely integral to how Russia's Army
supplies itself and taking out that
crucial link across the the Kurt
straight means that basically it's going
to be very very difficult for those
troops uh fighting for Russia to be
supplied
but then of course there's a
psychological blow this bridge was
effectively the cord that stitched uh
Crimea to Mainland Russia and told
Russians that these two would be linked
forevermore well if this was the
ukrainians that chord has now been
severed Vladimir Putin said that any
attack on Crimea and the other Annex
territories was an attack on Russia and
they would use all its means to defend
this we'll have to see how far he's
willing to take that Rory thank you for
that Rory challenge live there in Kiev
now let's just remind you about where
the explosion took place the area in red
is under the control of Russian forces
and their separatist allies the Kirch
Road and rail Bridge links Mainland
Russia and Crimea and is a vital and
land and rules supplying Russia's
military in southern Ukraine Ukrainian
forces have been pushing a
counter-offensive in the East and in the
southern kershan region now damage to
the Kirch Street Bridge appears to be
affecting Maritime traffic too tracking
websites show a buildup of vessels
around the passage the route is a
shipping Corridor for Russian ports in
the Black Sea to Ukrainian regions under
military occupation in the sea of azov